[Music]
straight ahead on lawn crime daily
you indicated that you have a very
negative
uh impression of kimberly
potter jury selection is underway in the
trial of ex-minnesota cop kim potter and
witnesses take the stand in day two of
elaine maxwell's federal trial we bring
in the latest from inside the courtroom
plus a new hampshire jury hears opening
statements as a man stands trial for the
murder of his wife the defendant's anger
and resentment toward mourning
intensifiers
phil argy did not hurt his wife and
later we hear from both sides in the
death of a mont arborete trial as
prosecutors it is actually very rare for
a defendant to actually take the stand
we felt that it would be the right thing
for him to step up first law on crime
daily covering court cases from coast to
coast
[Music]
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm brian buckmeyer along with terry
austin we begin with news out of
minnesota where the defense says ford
police officer kim potter will testify
in her own defense on charges of
manslaughter in the shooting death of
dante wright jury selection in the case
began on tuesday
in april of this year brooklyn center
and minnesota officers pulled over
wright for an expired registration tag
office determined he had an outstanding
warrant for a weapons charge and
attempted to take him into custody body
camera footage shows wright resisting
the officers potter warns right she will
tase him but instead of a stun gun she
pulls out her gun and shoots him in the
chest right a black man was unarmed at
the time he later died potter's defense
argues wright's death was an accident on
tuesday both sides questioned potential
witnesses about the highly publicized
trial
is it fair to say that what you're
telling us is it's not really personal
no
it's just a no
somebody's dead yeah just the
circumstances around the whole
thing
right
and obviously
you have some sympathy for a young man
who was killed of course and you know an
officer who made those
actions yes
and as you sit here today
you know can you tell the court that you
can set aside
those impressions
you know those feelings and decide the
case based solely on the evidence
presented to you in court
yes
joining us today is criminal defense
attorney adam conte and terry austin
adam i would expect the prosecution to
have a lot of police and use of force
experts in this trial does that affect
who either side will be looking for in a
juror
yeah of course i mean they're going to
be looking for a few things you're going
to be looking for jurors on the
prosecution side you're going to be
looking at jurors who don't have a bias
with police and have a bias against this
whole sort of
movement that's going on but also to be
open to the idea of what experts can
offer the idea just the very idea that
there can be a qualified expert that can
give opinion and have sort of a weighted
insight into a case i this is going to
be a very very tricky case that so much
of it is going to be done during jury
selection when there's this much that
you can see in the video it's just about
interpreting that video there's no other
evidence really it's just a 30 second
video so this case i really believe can
be won or lost right here right now in
quad deer absolutely it's amazing we
have the ability to record that but in
many cases we actually don't terry
opening statements expected on december
8th jury selection can be as long as it
was in brunswick georgia or as short as
it was in kenosha wisconsin how long do
you think selections will take here in
this case
well at first brian i thought it was
moving quickly i think it slowed down a
little bit they selected that first
juror very quickly now they have three
but they have plenty of time before
december 8th they have six more days all
together and if they want to do the 12
jurors i think they can do it plus the
alternates i've got to say i am
impressed by this judge he's deliberate
but she keeps the case on track so far
and both of the attorneys are being very
reasonable they're not perfect jurors
but they believe that these jurors will
listen to the evidence and they're
trusting that that's going to happen
absolutely it makes sense and will
obviously give you up-to-date
information as we continue with jury
selection in the case of minnesota v kim
potter switching now to federal court
out of arkansas where jury selection is
underway in the trial of josh duggar the
former reality tv star best known for
his family's show 19 kids and counting
is charged with possessing child
pornography back in 2019 authorities
traced child pornography downloads to
duggar's ip address the media involving
children as young as 18 months old was
found on a computer at duggar's car
dealership while the 33 year old was
arrested in april of this year
allegations of his illegal behavior date
back to nearly two decades in 2015 a
previously sealed 2006 police report was
released claiming duggars sexually
molested five girls as far back as 2002.
four of the victims were his sisters to
add to the mountain case months after
the molestation reports duggar admitted
to being unfaithful to his wife after
his profile on the extramarital affairs
site ashley madison was leaked ahead of
the trial prosecutors asked a federal
judge to allow them to use starr's
previous scandals to prove his allegedly
criminal conduct
the judge ruled the decision will be
under advisement if convicted duggars
faces up to 20 years in prison
just months after his release from
prison prosecutors asked the united
states supreme court to throw out the
ruling that freed comedian bill cosby
back in june a judge overturned cosby's
2018 conviction for sexual assault
saying the actor's rights had been
violated the ruling was based on a
verbal immunity agreement made in 2005
that qazi would not face charges when a
woman claimed he had drugged and
sexually assaulted her but in 2015 the
actor was arrested after the original
investigation was dropped and a
settlement was reached between the woman
and cosby
the arrest came after dozens of other
women came forward accusing cosby of
sexual assault or misconduct he served
less than three years in prison before
he was released in june cosby spokesman
andrew watt says
down with law sat down with law on
crime's own anjanet levy to talk about
the appeal we'll have more from the
interview on the next episode of law and
crime daily
still ahead on law and crime daily a new
hampshire and man on trial for the
murder of his wife but was it suicide
hear opening statements from both sides
and the trial of william argy
but first the federal sex trafficking
trial of gilain maxwell our own adam
classveld is live at the courthouse with
a takeaways from day two
[Music]
hi this is dan abrams with exciting news
for all of our law and crime followers
on youtube you can now get the live law
and crime network with youtube tv for
all of your daily live trial coverage
legal news expert analysis and original
true crime programs subscribe to youtube
tv today and then locate lawn crime in
the channel guide and for only 1.99 a
month you can add the network to your
bundle watch lawn crime every day with
youtube tv we put you in the jury box
[Music]
welcome back to law and crime daily
tuesday marks day two in the high
profile sex trafficking trial of elaine
maxwell the longtime companion of
disgraced financier jeffrey epstein
59 year old maxwell faces multiple sex
crime charges including sex trafficking
of a minor and enticing minors to travel
to engage in an illegal sex act the
charges stem from a long-time
relationship with epstein who
prosecutors say maxwell served up girls
too in 2019 epstein was found dead by
suicide following arrests on federal sex
trafficking charges
let's now go to the southern district of
new york courthouse where law and crime
network's adam classified is live and
adam you've been inside the courier for
all of maxwell's trial so far how did
things shape up on day two
well it was very emotional testimony
brian today we had
today in the afternoon session the
testimony of jane
the first accuser who the prosecution
introduced a jury to yesterday saying
that she was sexually abused by jeffrey
epstein and elaine maxwell when she was
14 years old now it was very emotional
testimony she her voice cracked at most
multiple occasions on the witness stand
she said late in the afternoon when
asked about the long-term effects of
this abuse
that
compared it to being a broken compass
said how do you have in how do you have
healthy relationships when you're acting
with a broken compass and spoke about
the devastation the toll of it this was
one of the most sought after testimony
immediately following uh jeffrey
epstein's pilot speaking about
about her on the witness stand earlier
thanks adam as we know we can't go
inside the corpsman's a federal
courthouse with no cameras so we
appreciate and thank you so much for
bringing the courtroom to us in this
later edition of elaine maxwell's
federal court case we'll make sure to
catch up with you next time
thank you very much brian yeah coming up
on law and crime daily new insight on
the ahmad armory trial as we hear from
the defense and the prosecution after a
guilty verdict just last week plus we
take you inside the new hampshire
courtroom where both sides deliver
opening statements in the trial of
william argy
[Music]
welcome back to law and crime daily
opening statements are given in new
hampshire well william bill argey is
accused of murdering his wife maureen
prosecutors say the 46 year old killed
his wife by strangling or smothering her
she was 39 years old argy was the only
beneficiary on her 400 thousand dollar
life insurance policy prosecutors say
argy lost his job as a physician's
assistant and accumulated mounting debt
as a gambling addict they say argy asked
a friend to help kill his wife and when
he declined argie asked for his help
hiring a hitman authorities say argy
killed his wife then attempted suicide
after he threw away his cell phone and
gambled at a casino
in opening statements on monday the
prosecution said argey showed no care
for his wife after her murder
prosecutors say after he tried to kill
himself rg ran away from the crime scene
showing no consideration for his wife
so the defendant
bandaged up his injuries
he took care of himself
he showed concern
for himself
but he showed no concern for maureen
for maureen he left her to rot in her
bed
and after he took her life
he took her car
and he took her phone
and drove away
free from the person whom he played
for all of his problems
he pled
no calls for help
no calls to family
you will see maps from the records
recovered during the investigation
documenting that while maureen laid dead
at 118 west road in londonderry
her phone left that residence and
continued connecting with cell phone
towers
all the way down to the nashua area
the defense countered the prosecution's
opening statement saying maureen argy
committed suicide they say bill argey
found her with a bed sheet tied around
her neck
it was a suicide
see in the middle of the night in a
moment of desperation maureen argy did a
terrible and tragic thing
you may never know exactly why she did
what she did
she left no note explaining her decision
she told no one
we know
is that on april 3rd
2019
maureen archie went upstairs alone
she went to bed alone
and she killed herself alone
let's bring back criminal defense
attorney adam conte and co-host terry
austin terry there are no witnesses or
other direct evidence in this case is
there enough circumstantial evidence
here to convict argie
brian it would be great to have an
eyewitness or even a videotape of this
but there is plenty of circumstantial
evidence to convict william rg first of
all we have that neighbor's security
camera that the prosecution mentioned
where you see him going in and out of
the house and no one else going in and
out we also have those matching cell
phone records where he took the phone of
him and his wife and took the phone and
drove to go gambling and so we have
those tower records where everything is
matching up and that shows that he's
trying to get away and then we have the
most important witness who was his
friend talking about the fact that r.g
wanted him to
kill his wife and then when his friend
said no i'm not going to do that he
asked his friend to help him find
someone to do it i think all of that
together is going to definitely help
with the conviction and finally we have
his daughter who actually opened the
door and saw her mother lying in the bed
there so there's enough evidence
adam the defense opened kind of big in
this case with uh saying how argy found
his wife does the opening suggest
opening statement sorry suggest to you
that rg may actually testify in this
case
it doesn't necessarily suggest that but
i think that it's extremely likely the
only way that the story that the
defense attorney opened really gets in
front of the jury other than them just
sort of saying it as conjecture is going
to be from him so he's going to need to
get up there he's gonna need to emote
and say how
shocking and just viscerally mentally
damaging it was to walk in and find his
wife this way it was so shocking that he
needed to drive and
almost commit suicide himself and then
gamble you know i think he's going to
need to get that out in front of the
jury himself so i don't know if the
opening necessarily suggests it but i
think this case suggests it if that
makes sense i think he's just going to
need to say
uh to the jury what happened this his
version in order to have any shot here
at an acquittal yeah because otherwise
the evidence as as lin as as in pointing
out by terry uh the family members the
the the friend who's suggesting that
that he came to him to ask to kill the
wife and then hire the hitman there's
got to be some sort of explanation of
hey i was merely joking with my friend
you know how guys get around we have a
couple beers or whatever and then of
course as you point out adam the finding
of his wife's body and the acts that he
does afterwards would be bizarre to
anyone going out and drinking and going
to casino afterwards but if he can get
on the stand and explain that away
maybe at the very least he beats the top
counts maybe a full quota we don't know
but we'll keep up as we continue in this
new hampshire versus william argy when
we come back for the first time since
the verdict law and crime network hears
from both sides in the death of a mont
arbory trial
what defense attorneys and prosecutors
have to say about trousing michael's
testimony on the stand that's next
[Music]
welcome back to law and crime daily just
one week after a georgia jury found
three men guilty in the death of a mod
arbory we're hearing from both the
prosecution and defense about the trial
itself
last wednesday father and son travis and
gregory mcmichael and william roddy
bryan were found guilty in february 2020
death of a mod arbory mcmichael shot and
killed aubry as he was jogging near his
brunt of georgia home meg michonne's
father tailed aubry and ryan recorded
the incident on his cell phone trousy
michael was found guilty on all nine
counts gregory mcmichael received one
not guilty verdict and brian received
three not guilty verdicts all three men
face life in prison on tuesday
prosecutor linda donakowski told lawn
crime network how her team prepared for
trousing michael to take the stand
when any defendant takes the stand it is
a challenge because the biggest fear for
prosecutor is that they're going to come
off as sympathetic or that some juror is
going to feel sorry for them or buy
their story now we had analyzed as a
team his statements repeatedly and we
had actually developed a
cross-examination that we rehearsed paul
actually played travis mcmichael and we
practiced it now of course as you know
no cross-examination plan survives
contact with the enemy and we had to
pivot because you never know where the
defendant's going to go you never know
what he's going to agree to what he's
not going to agree to and when he
disagrees with something you've said and
you know full well that that's a lie
you've got to be able to pull up the
transcript of his prior statements and
question him about those things
trouser michael's attorney jason
sheffield also spoke with law and crime
network he says his client was adamant
he must tell his side of the story
the first moment that we saw travis
there in a jail cell
right after he had been arrested and we
took on his representation
he was adamant that he needed to explain
himself
fortunately we felt the same way because
in a case such as this
where you have taken another man's life
and you've done so because you believe
that you yourself were about to die
you have to explain that fear you have
to explain that thinking to the jury and
so instantly we were connected on the
idea that travis was going to testify
it was our call that he testify first
and that he do so prior to any other
witness testifying on his behalf
because we did not want the jury to
think or feel that he had the benefit of
other witnesses
testifying about him or about his
experiences or about the neighborhood
adam you've had this conversation as a
defense attorney with a client whether
or not they should testify it's
absolutely their right but your thoughts
on trusting michael testifying in this
case
yeah i was just in rikers island
yesterday having this conversation
uh and it's a very tough one i think a
lot of attorneys are scared to put their
clients on and it is sort of rare but
i'm not scared of it and i don't think
other attorneys should be either and i
think what he said is correct it didn't
work but there was no way there's no way
for a jury to really get the sense of
what someone's feeling without them
saying it so in a case like this where
he's saying self-defense and it doesn't
look like self-defense you watch that
video it's visceral it does not look
like self-defense so if you're going to
try to convince a jury of that you got
to get up there you got to really put
yourself into it you got to really have
the emotion and and express the fear
that you were feeling so i think it made
a lot of sense even though you know
listen it's easy to quarterback a monday
morning quarterback and say oh it didn't
work it was a bad decision i don't think
it was i think it was the right call it
was just a tough evidence yeah and i
think to jason sheffield's credit as
well the order in which he wanted
trousers and michael to testify was also
very important you don't want to put him
on the back burner as a witness who's
heard all the other testimony from his
side and then is trying to say hey well
you heard what everyone else said this
is what i think as well so putting him
first and foremost especially before the
other defendants was pretty good uh at
least in my opinion terry looking at how
the prosecution prepared for this trial
does the result surprise you and was
there a part of their prep that stood
out to you
listen linda donakowski was amazing she
was the epitome of excellent lauren
nothing surprised me and it is no wonder
that when she came out of that trial she
got a hero's welcome the key to winning
any case is preparation and presentation
and donakowski did both she gathered
every single piece of evidence she and
her team they reviewed all of the
transcripts to make sure they knew what
travis mcmichael was going to say on the
stand and she surgically executed that
cross-examination so i think you could
not have done better and by the way her
closing and opening were engaging she
did exactly what she was supposed to do
and that's why they won the case
absolutely flying colors all around for
the prosecution team thank you both and
thank you for joining us here on law and
crime daily we'll see you next time as
we discuss justice in america
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you